the reason to win the game is so that
you can be free of it and my questions
about this are
wait one more time the reason to win the
game is so that you can be free of it i
would be curious to know
what game
you are free of or what game you are
playing so that you can be free of it i
like to think i'm free of almost all the
games at this point what are the games
all of life is games right you start out
with the family game you do the school
game the grades game the getting
girlfriends and boyfriends game the
getting married game the having kids
game the the making money game the
having the career game the getting
famous game the dressing well game you
know it's so much of a social games
there are a few that are not games like
meditation you're not doing if you're
scoring points in meditation you're
doing it wrong yoga these are single
player games right so it's really the
multiplayer games are the ones that suck
you into society and into anxiety now
you kind of have to play them you have
two choices towards peace in your life
one is you can play these games and you
can win them and when you win them this
is the hard part realizing you've won
and stop playing new ones or setting new
goals for yourself that are even higher
and higher it's like my friends who have
made so much money and they continued
all they try to do is make money and
they just don't seem very happy about it
it's fine if they're happy if they're
like elon musk seems like he's having a
grand old time
that's fine but if it's making you
miserable and you continue doing it and
you only have one life and you kind of
can't see past that then i would argue
you're playing the game too far so
there's kind of two ways out of the trap
one is
not wanting something is as good as
having it right i think it was lyad
shabo said this on twitter i thought it
was really good or there's a recent
socrates quote that i retweeted where he
was taken to uh the story is he was
taken to a a market back in ancient
greece and it was full of luxurious and
fine items and he said there are so many
things that i do not want
right and it was he looked at all these
fineries and said so many things here
that i do not want and i thought that is
freedom that is power that is
self-contained uh that is a person who
has found himself and needs nothing
outside of himself that is so
inspirational so the same way i look
upon the world and i say well i could
just say that right you can't just say
that if i just said there's so many
things that i don't want it's not true i
want the money i want the girl you know
i want i wanted the fame or i wouldn't
have gone on podcast and i wouldn't be
on twitter at some level that is true so
obviously there are certain things that
i want i'm not a monk i'm not a i'm not
living in ashram but what i can do is
i've gotten the things that i want and
i'm careful not to want more i don't
want more fame i don't want more money
or if i get it's fine it's part of the
crafts by the bonus you know so i have
to be careful about what i about not
unconsciously taking on new desires if
i'm taking a new desire i better go
fulfill that so these are all just games
that i'm playing and you know you got to
play some game you're on this planet
you're alive you might as well play
something now the question is what game
do you play and how do you get out of
the game so you're not just trapped
playing that game forever and one way is
you choose your games very carefully if
you're a monk you only choose very very
few games to play or you play no games
and you live content blissful harmonious
peaceful
or the other is you play the game and
you win it and then you say i am now
free of this so what that tweet is that
tweet is the reason to play the game so
the reason to win the game is to be free
of it
it's a reminder to myself
that for the games that i've won it's
time to let go of them and to be free of
them and not to unconsciously double
down by comparing myself to the joneses
and continuing to level up and level up
and level up and level up and then one
day you die and then you're like okay
that was pointless like you know i i did
all that work for what like for nothing
so if you're not enjoying it anymore if
you've already won the game by the
definition you had when you started
playing the game and one hack is to set
the definition early on so that when you
go past it you know you won
to not get trapped into playing this
game forever and just living in some
anxious future as opposed to actually
enjoying yourself in the present you
have to know when to stop playing the
game and so to me the reason to play
these games is to win them and then you
can be free of them and to see what else
then that you want to do or not do not
to keep playing the same game forever
because these games are the adult games
are very cleverly designed you can keep
playing them infinitely and they're all
ups and downs and ups and downs and i
guarantee you every time you get money
you'll be afraid you're going to lose it
or you're going to compare it to the
next person who has it or every time you
get famous now that's that's a that's
the image that you have to live up to
and now insults can hurt you and now you
don't have your privacy anymore as
you've written about so all of these
games have downsides or if you're uh you
know very you're good at dating you have
a lot of men or women in your life then
you're also going to have a lot of
relationship trauma and you've got a lot
of tumultuousness you know a lot of hurt
people you got a lot of emotional drama
in your life so you just have to kind of
realize when you won the game and say
i'm done with this so i i would aspire
to be like socrates and say there are so
many things in this world that i do not
want and i like to think that i'm kind
of there for the most part either i
don't want it or i have it now of course
there's a fear of losing it which is
always there but i don't want to pick up
new desires unconsciously and i don't
want to keep upgrading my lifestyle and
my expectations to match my
circumstances otherwise i'll be on this
treadmill forever
we are all playing games and
the key is
knowing which game
you are playing so you can at least
attempt to consciously choose the game
finite and infinite games by james
carso's
an interesting read
[Music]
you